من المقرر أن يفوز بكأس العالم في قطر بشكل
لا مثيل له ، ليس فقط
لأنها المرة الأولى التي تقام فيها هنا في
الشرق الأوسط ، وكل ذلك بسبب الوقت من
العام ، الحجم مختلف تمامًا ،
لذا دعنا نذهب ونرى ما أنا عليه.
بالحديث عن
[الموسيقى]
هذه هي أصغر دولة على الإطلاق
تستضيف البطولة مما يعني أن المشجعين
سيكونون قادرين على الذهاب إلى أكثر من لعبة
واحدة في اليوم ، حيث يستغرق الأمر أقل من ساعة
للسفر بين الأماكن الواقعة في أقصى
الشمال والجنوب.
ملعب مصير مثل
واحة خضراء في الصحراء حيث سيلعب مضيف
تاتا
المباراة الافتتاحية
للبطولة ويتحدث عن الضغط
ستكون أول مباراة له على الإطلاق في
نهائيات كأس العالم مع أنظار العالم
تراقب في 21 نوفمبر.
للمرة الأولى في تاريخ كأس العالم ،
ستكون هناك أربع مباريات في اليوم
مع دورة تستمر 28 يومًا فقط
[موسيقى]
هنا
يمكنني رؤية أربعة ملاعب مختلفة
في موقع واحد
فقط ، وهناك ثمانية ملاعب فقط تم
بناؤها حديثًا بأسلوب يغلفها  بعض
التقاليد والثقافة المحلية مثل
alpha marma التي تشبه
قبعة منسوجة تقليدية أو استاد الجنوب
الذي يرمز إلى
تاريخ البلاد الغني في صيد الأسماك والغوص بحثًا عن اللؤلؤ ،
والاستثناء المحتمل لذلك هو الملعب
974 هنا ، حيث تم إنشاء أول
ملعب لكأس العالم قابل للفك
من حاويات الشحن
974 منهم تكريمًا لرمز الهاتف القطري لدولة قطر ،
تشك في أن معظمنا لن يتمتع
برفاهية طائرة هليكوبتر خلال
البطولة ، ولكن هناك دائمًا
خطوط المترو المبنية حديثًا ونظام طرق مطور ،
لذا فقد يكون هذا بمثابة توقف صافرة
جولة ولكن من المؤكد أنها كانت بمثابة
بناء طويل لمنظمي البطولة في
نهاية المطاف ، على الرغم من أن الفرق الـ 32
ومشجعيهم يتعلق الأمر بالوصول
إلى ملعب الحلزون الفضفاض لاستضافة نهائيات
كأس العالم لأول مرة على الإطلاق في نهائي ديسمبر ،
وهذا هو ديفيد سي إن.